today on the matt well show the biden
administration earned yesterday the
ignoble distinction of being the first
administration in history to fly a trans
flag outside of a government building
they're also the first to officially
endorse chemically castrating children
also camilla harris once again
humiliates herself by trying to say
sentences out loud biden receives his
fourth covet shot live on camera caitlyn
jenner gets a job with fox news and a
deep dark secret about clarence thomas
is exposed you have to see this to
believe it it's pretty sinister stuff
and in our daily cancellation we will
for the last time revisit slap gate to
talk about the real villain in the whole
debacle who has so far been let off the
hook but i can't let that happen we'll
talk about all that and more today on
the matt wall show
[Music]
did you know that if you're currently on
a phone plan with one of the major
carriers you're helping these
left-leaning companies donate to
pro-choice causes and candidates a lot
of people didn't know that but a common
question i get from my listeners is what
can i do to help turn the tides in the
culture war here's a great first step
defund the abortionists don't let them
take your money and use it to further
policies that you don't believe in
switch to charity mobile today and
they'll send five percent of your
monthly plan price to any pro-life
charity of your choice charity mobile
offers the latest 5g phones with no
device or service contracts plus great
nationwide service if this sounds like a
hassle i assure you it is not charity
mobile makes switching from your current
carrier painless their live customer
service is exceptional and will guide
you through the process you can keep
your number
and and your phone in most cases or if
you want you can take advantage of my
special offer and get a free cell phone
with free activation all you have to do
to take advantage of this is call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com mention offer code
walsh to redeem the free cell phone
offer that's charitymobile.com mention
offer code walsh join the fight for the
life of children by switching to charity
mobile today
well yesterday as we talked about on the
show the sacred feast day known as the
trans day of visibility began with
several major announcements from the
bible administration the most startling
of which was the new policy allowing
non-binary quote-unquote americans to
list their gender as x on their
passports there are many reasons to
oppose such a system of course and we
talked about a lot of them but i'm sure
other countries especially the
non-western world are actually grateful
for the change because now they can
easily identify the sorts of people they
don't want to allow in
naively i thought the passport thing
would be the most ludicrous and
confounding bit of virtue signaling from
the button administration that day
i mean not like permanently but i just
thought that day it's not going to get
any worse today at least
i should have known better this is after
all the most disgraceful deranged
morally vacuous and anti-american
presidential administration in american
history
lots of competition for that title but
really when you think about it there's
no competition at all
i mean obama's regime was downright
conservative compared to what biden's
handlers with biden as the figurehead
are doing it's worth reminding ourselves
that barack obama the most liberal
president in history to that point
was elected as a proponent of biblical
marriage
that's how far down the slippery slope
we have slid in just a decade and a half
and so things only got worse as the day
went on
many different governmental departments
agencies etc all took their term
broadcasting their lgbt allegiance the
air force was among them marking the
occasion with a video featuring
lieutenant colonel bree fram who's the
highest-ranking openly transgender
officer and listen to this
you are an inspiration to many right uh
you are breaking barriers and um it's
important though for us i think for
everyone to understand kind of what
motivates you right what keeps you what
inspires you what keeps you motivated
you know what really keeps me motivated
is the people that are going to come
after us some people have called me a
trailblazer in some of the things that i
do and that's something i really embrace
because what that means is that it's not
about me it's about the fact that the
road behind me is now paved and the
generation coming after us has an easier
chance to make it to where i've made it
to make it where so many others have
made it but then they've got the time
and the energy to go further so if we
can set the conditions where the folks
after us get to do even greater things
i'm thrilled
a trailblazer sure i mean uh well he is
probably the first male military officer
in recent history to wear his hair that
long
because that's
all it takes of course this is a
white man who's a trailblazer in the
military i mean you know because you
present yourself and it's like well
you're just a white man uh nothing
nothing to see here then you grow your
hair out and it's oh my gosh you're a
trailblazer
other than the hair thing it's hard to
see what trail he's blazing exactly
meanwhile biden himself addressed the
nation to broadcast his lgbt bonafides
let's listen to some of that for some
reason
today we're announcing even more steps
but there's always more work to do
to end the epidemic of violence against
transgender women of color and girls of
color
to ensure transgender seniors can age
with dignity dignity
and to finally pass a bipartisan
equality act
to help transgender persons around the
world live free from discrimination and
violence
above all to be there with you
to parents of transgender children
affirming your child's identity one of
the most powerful things you can do to
keep them safe and healthy
any transgender american who's
struggling please know that you're not
alone
to parents and children alike
please ask for help
and know this
you're so brave
you belong
and we have your back
god bless you all be brave
needless to say the bit about uh there
being an epidemic of violence against
trans people is a total fabrication
biden didn't fabricate it himself i mean
it's doubtful he even knows what he's
saying or why he's standing there in
front of cameras at all this is a
long-established false narrative used by
activists in reality there is no hate
crime epidemic against trans people it
doesn't exist it's not happening there
is zero evidence of such a thing
um and biden also urges parents to
affirm their child's identity and on
that actually we we agree
it is of utmost importance especially
these days
that parents affirm and fortify their
children in their identities
their actual identities their biological
identities
teach them to embrace who they are who
they really are
turn them away from delusion and
confusion and towards reality and truth
now of course when biden talks
uh or calls on parents to affirm their
child's identity he means the opposite
of all of that he means affirm them in
their non-identity
affirm them in a fantasy affirm them in
nothingness
and just leave them there floating in it
with no idea of which way is up which
way's down
speaking of which the administration got
into even more specific specifics
yesterday about how this affirmation
should happen here's the daily wire
report reading now it says early
transgender surgeries hormone treatment
and affirmations are quote crucial for
the health of kids and teens who
identify as transgender non-binary
president biden's administration said in
messaging released on thursday the white
house flagged a resource from the office
of the assistant secretary for health on
transgender day of visibility intended
to quote inform parents and guardians
educators and other persons supporting
children adolescents with information on
what is gender affirming care and why
it's important to transgender non-binary
non-binary and other gender expansive
young people's well-being
what is gender affirming care exactly
well the administration has its
euphemistic way of explaining that back
to the article says gender affirming
care is a supportive form of health care
the office of the assistant secretary
for health sheet says it consists of an
array of services that may include
medical surgical mental health and
non-medical services for transgender and
non-binary people for transgender and
non-binary children and adolescents
early gender affirming care is crucial
to overall health and well-being as it
allows a child or adolescent to focus on
social transitions and can increase
their confidence while navigating the
healthcare system the white house said
transgender surgeries hormones and
affirmations are important the white
house claim because these procedures
have been shown to increase positive
outcomes for transgender and non-binary
children adolescents gender affirming
care is patient-centered and treats
individuals holistically aligning their
outward physical traits with their
gender identity according to the white
house
so just to be totally clear here
this is the white house officially
endorsing the idea that we should
chemically castrate little boys and chop
the breasts off of little girls
it's not the first time they've come out
in favor of such barbarity of course but
it's it's still remarkable i remind you
again barack obama was against gay
marriage when he was elected fast
forward just a few years his vice
president is now president and is
issuing presidential proclamations about
the wondrous benefits of castrating
children
we must holistically align their
physical traits with their gender
identity says the white house well
that's like saying you should fix a
problem with your car's engine by
getting a paint job only that analogy
doesn't really work because a paint job
can actually improve your car if only
slightly it's not going to prove the way
it runs but it can be some improvement
there in this case you're trying to fix
a problem with the engine
by taking a sledgehammer to the exterior
a child who's a child whose gender
identity quote unquote
misaligns with his physical body
has a problem in his mind that's a quite
understandable problem given how
confusing we have made the world for him
what he needs is help with his mind help
that could easily be offered
if only he wasn't surrounded by people
determined to deepen and encourage his
identity crisis
towards the end of the day yesterday as
the
last indignity
the hhs secretary tweeted this
says on this international trans day of
visibility to our transgender
communities we see you we stand with you
and we'll be there for you for the first
time in history the transgender flag is
flying in front of a federal agency
which is the uh
hubert humphrey building in dc
so the trans flag right below the
american flag
flying in front of a government building
a flag for a
sexual identity
flying
right below our nation's flag
now one might consider it a small
blessing that at least they didn't put
the trans flag above the american flag
or even take down the american flag
entirely for the trans flag
that day will come soon enough
because this administration has made its
allegiances known
and those allegiances are not to america
or americans
but to the radical left now let's get to
our five headlines
[Music]
so we're going to start here because i
just think this is great we know that
camilla harris is a wordsmith
we're used to hearing her speak with
great eloquence
but there are moments where she exceeds
even the already lofty expectations that
we have for her as an orator
and moments just like this let's listen
to this
we also recognize just as it has been in
the united states for jamaica one of the
issues that has been presented as an
issue that is economic in the way of its
impact has been the pandemic
so to that end we are announcing today
also that we will assist jamaica in
covid recovery um by assisting in terms
of the recovery efforts in jamaica that
have been essential to i believe what is
necessary to strengthen not only uh the
the the issue of public health but also
the economy
so for jamaica one of the issues that's
been presented as an issue that is
economic in the way its impact and which
is an issue in the terms of
being an issue which is economic and
impactful in its economic impact
is the pandemic and we will assist
jamaica in covet recovery by
assisting in terms of the recovery
efforts and in terms of the assistance
efforts to assist in the recovery and
recover our assistance which will
greatly assist with the recovery
as the recovery
requires assistance
you know she seemed i've said uh before
that
she really reminds me of myself
in seventh grade
uh giving a book report about a book i
didn't read
um so that's that's what always comes to
mind when i hear her talk
but but even more than that it's like
there's there's it's it's hard to
understand what exactly psychologically
is going on i don't know if maybe her
handlers for whatever reason
are telling her that
okay
you need to get up there and talk about
the jamaica recovery efforts but you
have to talk for seven minutes
just you only have two sentences to say
but
you need to talk for seven i don't know
if that's what's happening
i don't know if she has some weird
and maybe this is in the dsm they've got
everything else there but it's some
weird mental illness where she's afraid
of ending a sentence
like she's afraid of punctuation
and she doesn't want to end a sentence
so so every time she's in a sentence she
feels that she needs to just keep it
going and going and going because that's
what i detect
you can almost see the panic in her face
as she's as she feels herself getting
towards the end of a sentence and she
has to just keep adding words on to it
it really is amazing um elsewhere in the
white house this week biden himself
stumbled and uh bumbled around on stage
while receiving his covet shot this is
now his fourth coveted shot that he has
received
and uh let's
let's just watch a little bit of this
scene here
so now i'm gonna get my second booster
shot
his second booster shot
the fourth shot all together
mr president what is the danger of putin
being left in the dark by his military
advisors
he looks totally lost and
confused doesn't trust his military
leadership why would you do this
no
what's that what's the idea
what's the plan for the white house here
why would you
i don't understand why you're putting
this guy in front of cameras at all
anymore
but especially in a situation like this
where it's off script you have him
walking
first of all never have joe biden
move on camera at all we've seen what
that looks
like what did president zalinski tell
you now you're putting him in front of
an audience in front of cameras
no script
and he's just sitting there looking
confused he has no idea why he's there
he doesn't know what they're injecting
into him
i don't think anyone knows that they're
having injected into them when they get
the booster shot but um
all right
then he gets his booster shot
he's totally he's laughing what's he
laughing about all right let's let's cut
out of this it's just depressing
that's a confused man here's look here's
a story that
that may may not seem related
but i think it is
um you've probably heard the thing about
bruce willis and he retired from acting
this week after it was revealed
that he was suffering cognitive decline
stemming from uh
brain damage
likely suffered during a stroke
and so now apparently he doesn't he
doesn't have much memory doesn't really
understand where he is and um
and it's really really quite a sad thing
he's only you know in his late 60s and
he's retiring from acting because of it
well now reports from outlets like the
la times have come out indicating that
everybody around bruce willis knew this
was another one of those open secrets in
hollywood apparently everyone everyone
knew that this was happening that bruce
willis was kind of losing his mind and
they knew about his mental state and yet
he was being exploited by his inner
circle and his handlers sent out to keep
doing these crappy cheap movies for
quick paydays i mean he's
he's losing his cognitive faculties
and yet
bruce willis was putting out like eight
movies a year and all of them were going
directly to streaming or going right one
of those movies it's not even on stream
it goes like red box or something um
just these not even b movies
and that was raising questions even
among just
average fans like why is he why is he
doing all this i know he's getting paid
for it but
um
well now now we start to understand
that the people around him
just they knew that he couldn't go do
like a real movie with with actual
acting involved or we'd have to memorize
a script so they just had them doing all
these terrible movies collecting you
know two million dollars here two
million dollars there that would then
funnel down to them
um
he's being propped up right and shuffled
along for the benefit of the people
around him or exploiting him and it kind
of reminds you of someone doesn't it
very similar situation happening in the
white house i would say
is why
i mean i i've been hesitant to say this
but i know more uh more and more we're
hearing from conservatives
over the last few weeks especially
that you know this is a 25th amendment
situation this is uh
he needs to be removed from office
and of course you haven't hesitated to
say that because that means that camille
harris takes charge
hard to see that as an improvement
but as wild as it's as it sounds when
you say it out loud she actually would
be an improvement because at least
she's basically cognizant
and it is a serious national security
threat to have somebody like this
running the country
it'd be a national security emergency to
have camel harris running it but maybe
slightly less so because at least she's
at least she's conscious
at a minimum
most of the time
seems to lose consciousness while she's
speaking a lot but i mean we can assume
she's got a little bit more of it than
joe biden does
um
it is it is a it's hard for me to feel
so i don't feel sorry for joe biden
because he even before he started losing
his mind
he's been obsessively pursuing power you
know his whole life and so he did put
himself in this position so he of course
has a lot of the blame for the position
that he's in
but i also put a lot of the blame course
around his handlers and also his wife
what kind of terrible wife do you have
to be what kind of terrible wife is jill
biden
that she's
going along with this
you know that she's that she's
she is one one of the people shuffling
joe biden along
um
you know you need to look out for your
spouse
and if you're married to someone who's
losing their mind and says i want to run
for president you say no you're not
uh but she want to be what she wanted to
be a first lady she wanted to be in the
white house too and she doesn't really
care about joe all that much all right
this is from yahoo says after a failed
gubernatorial bid last fall caitlyn
jenner has found a new gig hired as a
fox news contributor
the former reality star in olympic gold
medals will offer commentary and
analysis across fox news channel on
various fox news media platforms
uh jenner who's 72 now
will make her
using the language in this article his
official debut thursday night on hannity
which um
which he's appeared on before so that's
the news is caitlyn jenner is now a fox
news contributor and he did appear on
sean hannity last night we have some of
that club i want to play a little bit of
this let's watch had a lot of talks
actually even with you sean and other
people at fox when we were negotiating
this deal as you know as you might know
i am trans and but i'm not a trans
activist
um that's just one part of my life uh
there's so much more to me
um but i think in the next in the
midterms coming up
lgbt issues are going to be very big
issues and i'm looking forward to
covering those but there's so much more
to me than that
obviously in 1976
i think was the best olympics of all
time it was our our bicentennial our
country was 200 years old patriotism was
at its height i have been a patriot my
whole life and my father fought in world
war ii my mother's 95
hi mom
and uh she's a patriot i grew up that
way and i want to i want that to
continue i want to
i was so proud to be the first person
put the american flag up and i want to i
want to continue that
okay
so jenner says he's not an activist
not a trans but not a trans activist
um
there are conservatives who seem to
like to put
jenner out
in the front here especially when it
comes to the trans issues because
recently
jenner's come out against um
men competing against women in women's
sports and that sort of thing now he has
been all over the place on that issue
he's been back and forth on it not
exactly a consistent voice um same for
the issue with like uh giving drugs to
kids he's kind of been back and forth on
that as well
um
but even if he now finally
at the age of 72 has staked out some
ground here that he's gonna stay on
which is that we don't want males and
female sports uh don't drunk kids and so
on like that's the that's the right
point of view so
good for him
but it's a
it's an incoherent
coming from jenner
it's an incoherent argument
because
the only taking leah thomas for example
and generous said leah thomas should not
be racing against the females okay
but why
right the only reason why leah thomas
should not race against the females is
that he is not a female
that's the only reason there's no other
reason
if not for that fact
if not for the fact of his
non-femaleness his maleness then there
would be an issue
so the only reason to that the only
coherent reason
to oppose somebody like leah thomason
racing against women
is that he is not a woman
um
that's the only reason
that anyone could come up with to oppose
the only reason you need that's the
whole issue right there
but is is that jenner's position
would jenner say that leah thomas
is not a woman well no he wouldn't say
that
any more than he would say that he
himself is not a woman
so he obviously believes in
the ideology of transgenderism he's
quite obviously a proponent of that
and yet he's trying to draw a line here
and say well yeah but we don't want them
i either leah thomas is a woman or a man
one of the other
and if you say that he's a woman then
then your whole argument against having
him in women's sports makes no sense
so even though conservatives might think
it's good political strategy to take
somebody like caitlyn jenner make him
the face
of uh protecting women's sports or
whatever that's the worst strategy first
of all it doesn't work
the left doesn't care
you cannot play the identity politics
game against the left they invented the
game
they have rigged the game so that they
always win that's part of the rules of
the game
it's like trying to play a
it's like trying to play a board game
against a three-year-old
as far as they're concerned the one of
the rules here is that they get to win
so
you can't win the game anyway it's
impossible to do and also the the
position being articulated doesn't make
any sense
there is no way to defend women's sports
or defend children against this stuff
without going right at
gender ideology itself
and if you're not doing that
if you're just staying around the edges
of it then you're not going to be an
effective
advocate on this issue
similar topic here um still on the trans
day of visibility because it was uh it
was a major celebration yesterday what a
couple other clips i want to play for
you quickly nickelodeon first of all um
as we see how this is funneling down to
the kids so nickelodeon we know we know
we know what disney's all about
nickelodeon of course is uh no different
it's a lot worse actually
and um here is something they put out
celebrating the
trans day of visibility let's watch
in honor of international transgender
day of visibility meet time in
nickelodeon's 2021 kid of the year
finalist rebecca brussohofe growing up
in the lgbtq plus community has given me
a different perspective on how i see the
world trans kids are so much more than
their gender identity and it's so
important for people to listen to kids i
wish for a world where everyone can be
lifted up and celebrated so today and
every day we celebrate those who are
helping others realize that everyone
should be proud of what makes them who
they are
growing up in the lgbt community as
no child
should be in a position where they're
uttering a sentence like that
i mean you grow up in the lgb how about
just grow up as a child
you shouldn't be growing up in any
community other than
the neighborhood you live in
and if that's not uh bad enough
abc got in on the action they brought up
the parent of a quote trans child out
to talk about her experiences let's
listen to that there is work that we all
know that we all still need to do and we
are here for it 150
now you and your husband were known as
the parents of four boys in your
community before chassis transitioned so
what was that transition like for you as
a parent and what is your advice to
other parents who are on a similar
journey
so
when chazzi our daughter when she really
started to
communicate to us and that was at the
earliest moment that she actually had
words and language
to communicate to us who she truly was
we were a little surprised because we
didn't expect it and then as we just
literally
raised her
supported her just like all parents do
raising you know we're teaching her the
right values we're teaching her to give
back
you know one of her favorite things in
the world to do is to volunteer and be
in service to others you know that
surprise
evolves into something just really
cool and important and and that is the
realization that she's our daughter and
so what i would say
to all of those parents out there and
all the folks by the way
millions of folks still in our country
who say they've never met a transgender
or non-binary young person i would say
this i would say
these children are here
and they are wonderful and all all it
takes is love all right jen gross
handler of the gender cool project we
appreciate it jen thank you
no that's not that's not love that's uh
it's not hatred either i wouldn't say
that she hates her child i wouldn't say
that um i mean maybe she does there's a
lot more evidence for her hating her
child than her loving her child i would
say it's more indifference
just a total indifference to the
well-being of her child she says that
well all you have to do is meet a
transgender child it's not possible to
meet a trans child or a non-binary child
because it doesn't exist
what i what i can meet are children who
are victims of abuse such as your own
she tells us that
as soon as her daughter which is her son
had words to speak he was already
insisting that he was a girl or whatever
i just i don't
i don't believe i mean there may be some
parents out there who are crazy enough
to actually think that when their
two-year-old son says i'm a girl that
you should take it seriously like there
might be a few parents who are crazy
enough for that
but the vast majority of these parents
are
that lets them off the hook which i'm
not going to do gives them too much
credit they're not that crazy
because
you have to be insane
all you have to do if you spend any time
around a very young child and if you're
raising a very young child and you're
around them every day
then there's no mystery here
it's very clear that young children have
no grasp on reality whatsoever
and they go around all the time saying
things that don't make any sense
whatsoever and everybody knows that any
parent knows that
so if the boy even did say i'm a girl or
whatever and it's possible he never even
said that but even if he did
they were they were looking for that
moment they seized the opportunity to
take their child
who they do not love
and to turn him into
um an accessory
you know like a as in a fashion
accessory upon a prop
that they could parade around which is
why the next thing these parents always
do
what's the next step get it on instagram
get it on tik tok alert the media alert
the presses bring them to the marches
i mean if i'm even if i'm
could be even tempted to believe
that these parents have the best
intentions
i can't even be tempted to believe that
unless they're keeping all this to
themselves and treating it as a private
matter
even that i don't believe that there are
good intentions
but the moment you go out and alert the
media let me call the today show let me
call up abc news whatever
it's it's 100 clear what your actual
uh intentions and motivations are
all right let's move to something else i
mentioned this um
story about clarence thomas and i have
to tell you it's a little bit upsetting
aaron rupar who's a reporter left-wing
reporter
has dug up a pretty incredible story and
i think this is damning i have to say um
you may have already heard about some of
the revelations about ginny thomas who's
clarence thomas's wife and it just so
happens that we know clarence thomas was
in the hospital earlier in the week and
um
when he's in the hospital we weren't
sure about his condition and uh thank
god it seems like he's okay
but at the time there were conflicting
reports could be a serious medical thing
and and right when he's in the hospital
that's when the media starts releasing
all this information about his wife
you might almost think like they're
trying to kill him because they've
waited until he's in the hospital to
come out with this attack on his wife um
but the uh the damning revelations about
jenny thomas is that she's a
conservative and she believes things
that lots of people on the right believe
and she's had the gall to um
to talk about those beliefs if you can
believe it
and it's all it's all pretty terrible
but that's not the big news um this is
the clip that was making the rounds and
a lot of left-wing reporters were were
uh retweeting and stuff but listen to
this clip that rupar found
the best part of being a justice
it's first of all it's um
it'd be impossible
without you
i have to be honest i mean it would be
um
it's sort of like how do you run with
one leg
you can't i mean
um
it makes it whole
when i have my wife
my god
he loves his wife
this is this is incriminating i kick him
off the supreme court this put
arrest them both
they have been married for for decades
and they still deeply love each other
that's that cannot be allowed in america
that's that's uh we can't allow that
kind of perversion
he wants to tell you about the left that
they they really think that that's
damning somehow
that he loves his wife
and and why is it actually it's actually
quite sad because so many of these
people aaron rupar and and the rest of
them
um they've never they don't know what a
loving marriage looks like they didn't
see it in their own homes they didn't
grow up with one
you know they grew up in broken homes um
these are all a bunch of like latchkey
kids who grew up in broken homes and uh
and they just never seen it and now
maybe they're in relationships or in
marriages and they they they in a bad
marriage themselves and it's just this
self-perpetuating cycle
and so when they encounter
a loving marriage and they hear the
kinds of things that a man who loves his
wife will say about his wife they're
taking their they're in shock they can't
believe it it doesn't make any it
doesn't compute
i mean just think about how they reacted
all those years to mike pence and still
do to mike pence and and his wife
another damning revelation that
mike pence doesn't go on like dinner
dates with other women because he's
married
and they still that that
that secret came out five six years ago
they still haven't gotten over it they
cannot believe it's like what do you
what you're saying
when you're married to a woman and you
love her then you you want to be with
her and not some other women woman and
you don't date other people what
fidelity loyalty i don't just it doesn't
compute
um
to any normal sane person you listen to
that clip and you and what do you think
oh wow well that's that's i admire that
as a myself married 10 years i i look to
that that's uh that is my my goal to be
in that position at that age
you just you like claire all of the
things this is like especially with
clarence thomas
um
anytime a video clip comes out of
clarence thomas
and it's supposed to be something that
makes me dislike him
every single time it only makes me like
him more i think oh wow he's a great guy
it seems like
there's not a lot of those in dc so it
is a little bit hard to believe but
apparently
um
all right let's move now to the comment
section
[Music]
all right we'll uh do one video comment
as is the custom now
because i'm not going to press my luck
let's try clip
which one is it 14.
hey master mad it's your boy gibberish
back here again i just want to get your
opinions since we're on the subject of
groomers and
people that are harming children and
everything like that i wanted to get
your opinion on parents that smoke
cigarettes around their children
i personally believe that cigarettes
should be criminalized i don't think
america should be that free of a country
to where you can literally just spew out
cancerous chemicals onto people around
you
um but i want to get your opinion on
that since we are talking about kids and
everything um
it's also just like it should be
criminalized just because the excuse
smokers give is that oh you know i'm
stressed well
no one really cares if you're stressed
like i don't really have any sort of
feeling towards you that you're stressed
so there's no reason for you to try to
give me cancer
i just wanted to give your just get your
opinion on that and give my opinion as
well because i think more people need to
realize that cigarettes need to be
criminalized but other than that spg for
life thank you
i mean you're singing my tune with the
uh no one cares if you're stressed a bit
so i i'm with you on that part
um
and just in general as i've said before
we should all stop talking so much about
our stress and expecting everyone else
to care about it uh but as far as
cigarettes go i think um
look
the
the claim
that uh
that that secondhand smoke causes cancer
causes all these um causes all these
health problems uh among other people
obviously second hand i think
a lot of that has been
called into question to a certain extent
by um some of the research that's been
done over the last few years i know
there was one study i mean off the top
of my head i can't remember exactly i
know there was one study done i think
like in 2013 um big sample size
and trying to establish the connection
between secondhand smoke and cancer
and they weren't exactly able to do it
much to the surprise i think of the
researchers
um certainly i think we can say that's
uh just like passing by somebody on the
street who's smoking a cigarette that's
not going to cause not going to cause
you any problems not going to cause
cancer
the problem can only possibly arise when
it's
over the course of many years close
contact with somebody like being in the
same house as someone for years and
years and years where they're just
smoking all over the place and even then
in this one study that comes to mind
um
they
were only barely able to
make a connection between that and
cancer
and then and then also there were a lot
of ex sort of um
uh
promises exorbitant promises that were
made about once we start banning smoking
and we we kick it out of polite society
which we've done
uh we would start to see you know the
health benefits and measurable health
benefits because people aren't around
secondhand smoke anymore and i'm not
sure that we've actually seen that
either so
it's not it's not quite as
straightforward as you're as you're
making out to be i also have no dog in
this fight i don't smoke cigarettes um
so but i don't think the connection is
quite as clear
as you're making out to me and also the
other thing about cigarettes is that i
think we've done enough
right like it's
it's everybody knows that it's unhealthy
i mean it could not be they put it right
on the box they've got the psas it's
like they this is this is one thing
everybody knows this and it's good that
people know because they should
we've we've kicked smoking out of almost
every building
now if you want to
smoke like most either you can't do it
at all
or
they'll have you know a little
somewhere outside in the cold they have
a little circle where you can all the
smokers can huddle around in the
freezing cold smoking
and uh so i'm gonna say let's lay off
the smokers now that's my judgment i
think we've done enough we've we have
ostracized them from society enough
we have done quite enough to make clear
that it's unhealthy everybody knows that
they know it
and uh so just just lay off all right
that's my intelligent argument all right
um
conor says careful matt when you're set
what you're saying about the silent
majority of disney sounds a lot like
silence is violence i agree that more
conservatives should speak up i just
think we should encourage the sharing of
opinions without implying that we oppose
those who lack the bravery to speak up
ideologically speaking
i'm not saying silences violence i don't
think it implies that um
no silence is not violence here's what i
would say silence is or often can be
cooperation
and i think it's indeed not denying that
that if this evil thing is happening
and you know that it's bad
but you don't say anything
and you just kind of go along then
you're you are cooperating with it
uh implicitly
might not be
it might be unintentional it might not
be what you want to do but you are
so silent and there's there there are a
lot of people still
cooperating with all forms of evil in
our culture
um and that's
what the silent majority
claim tells me
if we are as conservative if we are
still even just taking disney aside if
we are the silent majority in the
culture even now
which conservatives will claim that we
are not sure if that's true
but then again shame on us
how have we allowed this to happen
i mean look at what's
if just take one one area the schools
and that these
radical
nut cases have taken over the school
groomers have taken over the school
system
how have we allowed that to happen we've
allowed it to happen largely through our
silence so i think it is cooperation
um
brady says walking around school today i
saw they were selling buttons that said
stop hate all i could think about was
how matt would rant on about how there
are plenty of good reasons to hate
things
well you're exactly right and the other
thing is the person who of course should
go without saying the person wearing the
stop hate button
doesn't believe that themselves because
i could guarantee there are all kinds of
things and all kinds of people that
person hates
which as a general principle is fine
because as
you're exactly right there's there's
nothing wrong with hate in and of itself
in fact it's a it's a good thing hate is
the other
side of love it's another dimension of
love
if you love
now i'm going on the rant that you
imagine i was going all i'll say is if
you if you love someone
then you're also going to have hatred
not hatred for them
but you're going to hate the things that
harm the person that you love so hatred
always comes with love if you don't have
hatred
in your heart and in your life then you
don't have love
um
so spoon says if you have a company with
one woke activist
and 99 silent conservatives you have 100
woke activists
in essence i think that kind of
summarizes what i said well in essence
you have you have one woke activist and
then 99 cooperators i would say
um
and uh
let's see finally cool papa j magic says
matt thank you for calling out the
libertarians today we need more of this
if you did this more often i'd finally
be able to stop watching
knowles altogether well look this is the
only i don't hear this is the only show
that you need here's the daily wire okay
um
and i guess i've already
destroyed my anti-libertarian
credentials by earlier coming out in
favor of uh in defense of smokers so
you know you can't win every battle you
know if there's one question i never
thought i'd have to seriously ask the
general public it's what is a woman but
unfortunately here we are and not only
am i asking the question i've made an
entire film and written an entire book
trying to answer it both are called what
is a woman and the book is now available
for pre-order what is a woman.com and
also on amazon where it just hit number
two on the bestseller charts in the
women's studies category actually was
number one so why are we saying number
two this is number one this is the
number one
oh it's number two now well it was
number one so let's go with what it was
you know this is forever a number one
best-selling women's study let's put
that in the copy not number two
i am the best-selling most prominent
women's studies scholar
in the world permanently
all right we'll continue keep going
so
help me find you know able to change the
copy right now i'm in the middle of
talking so help me find the answer to
this elusive question pre-order my book
what is a woman at what is a woman.com
or on amazon now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
i thought there could be some nice
symmetry here if um this week of shows
were to end exactly how it began talking
about a subject which i promise i'll
never speak of again after this moment
it's probably true that too much has
already been said about
slap gate but then again it's one of the
most entertaining news events to occur
in many years so you know we're always
kicking one dead horse or another
in our country so why not this one
still even though will smith's assault
of chris rock has been discussed debated
analyzed dissected interpreted examined
scrutinized in every possible way from
every possible angle seemingly there's
one point about the incident that has
not been made or at least not been made
enough or loudly enough and i'd be
remiss if i allowed the week to end and
officially retired from slap gate
discussions without bringing it up and
here's the point
um we know that will smith is a neutered
cuckold prone to violent and
performative rage
that much has been established and he's
received plenty of much-deserved
criticism because of that and also
plenty of not at all deserved support
and yet the biggest villain in this
whole situation the person who shares at
least as much of the blame if not more
has been left off the hook entirely and
that would be will smith's
wife and lots of other men's girlfriend
jada pinkett smith
before we talk about her role in the
slap that will live in infamy we should
take a look at jada's background now
aside from the fact that she's been an
actress for 30 years and has yet to
appear in a good movie in her entire
career
the first thing to establish by jada
pinkett smith is that she's extremely
weird and creepy
so for example here she is a few years
ago talking to her daughter
about how her grandmother taught her
that is taught jada about
self-pleasuring quote unquote at the age
of nine listen
my grandmother taught me
about self-pleasuring because she wanted
me to know that that pleasure was from
me exactly she didn't want me to fall
into the hands of a man and if he gave
me pleasure to think that that was him
and she taught me at nine
look at that woman's
well who's i don't know who that woman
is in pink
but she is so excited to hear about a
nine-year-old being taught about
masturbation
so
reflecting back on her experience of
being sexually groomed by her own
grandmother the bizarre lesson that jada
takes away from it is that sex is a
selfish pursuit when a woman is with a
man she says all the pleasure comes from
herself not from the man i'm not even
sure what that means exactly except this
is a twisted depraved woman
but this self-obsessed approach to life
came through i think most profoundly and
embarrassingly when jada sat down with
will smith on camera to discuss in
conspicuously unapologetic terms her
affair with another man a rapper named
august who is only a little bit older
than her son let's go back and watch
that again
as time went on i got into a different
kind of entanglement
with august and one thing i want to get
clear about and clean up one of the
things that was kind of swirling in the
press about
you giving permission which
is uh
you know the only person that could give
permission in in in that particular
circumstances myself yes exactly yeah
but what
august was probably trying to
communicate
because i could actually see how he
would perceive it as
permission because we were
separated amicably
and
i think he also wanted to make it clear
that he's not a home wrecker
which he's not i'm thinking so i mean
because this is your red table and you
like brought yourself to the red table
i think um you need to say clearly what
happened as far as what you and i
decided we were to
take our space and what happened yeah
and then i got into an entanglement with
august that's what i said an
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship absolutely i was in a lot
of pain and i was very broken
that's
maybe the most brutal video clip
in the history of the world that's
really hard to watch
um an entanglement she says
and the only thing she cares to clarify
to her husband when it comes to her
sexual entanglements with other men
is that she um she didn't need his
permission to sleep around
also she's the real victim because she
was hurting she was broken
another way to heal her pain was to have
sex with a rapper half her age
you know it's bad enough to be a
backstabbing adulterer in the first
place but jada wasn't satisfied with
that
she also had to traipse her broken shell
of a husband out in front of the cameras
and humiliate him publicly
all part of the fun for her i suppose
but remember she's still a victim in
spite of her awful toxic behavior
because she has alopecia so let's keep
that in mind
that brings us to the fateful night this
past sunday with her husband once again
humiliated himself in front of the world
and uh probably blew up his career in
the process
it was a decision he made uh and he
carries the blame for it but it's fair
to wonder what jada was doing while her
husband was getting up from his seat and
strolling towards the stage it's not
like he got up and ran by the way i mean
he got up and walked so she would have
time to stop him if she was interested
in stopping him how did she react what
was her role in all this
well somebody in the crowd captured the
immediate aftermath of the slap on their
cell phone and it gives a good view of
how jada responded let's watch that
here is an angle most people have not
seen
look at jada's reaction
so
she's sitting in her seat watching this
all unfold and laughing
that's how she responded by laughing
what kind of wife responds that way as
her husband destroys himself
here's something that all young women
out there ought to know before you get
married okay
part of your job as a wife
is to stop your husband from doing
impulsive self-destructive stupid things
now i'm not saying this is a full-time
job hopefully he won't need
round-the-clock supervision in this
regard teenage boys are a different
matter right i mean they'll find 50
different ways to unintentionally
destroy themselves and ruin their lives
every day but if they survive male
adolescence and make it to adulthood
they'll have probably calmed down
considerably but even so every once in a
while as men we get it into our heads to
do something outlandishly ridiculous and
potentially harmful to ourselves and we
need our wives there to talk some sense
into us
there's a reason why married men live
longer than unmarried men this is the
reason
so i'll give one example from my own
life just as an example so as you heard
on the show a few months ago at one of
my recent college talks i decided to go
outside and physically confront a mob of
angry protesters in the street
why did i do this well mostly because i
thought it would be funny and it was but
it was also not the smartest thing to do
from a physical safety perspective
my wife was not there to stop me if she
had been she would have thrown herself
in front of the door to prevent me from
risking my safety for the sake of a joke
she was not able to stop me though she
wasn't there we did we did have a a a
a discussion about it after the fact and
now every time i have a speech she
implores me not to throw myself into the
middle of any more angry mobs and she
checks in with me repeatedly through the
night to make sure that i am keeping
that promise it kind of ruins my fun to
be honest but
i recognize that she's doing her job as
a wife that's what wives are supposed to
do so i appreciate that
if jada was a good wife who loved her
husband
she would have leapt up from her chair
grabbed will as he headed to the stage
and said something like what the hell
are you doing
and will would have responded well i'm
gonna go smack chris rock in the face in
the middle of the oscars because he made
fun of you
and jada would have said are you insane
have you lost your mind entirely did you
smoke crack on your way here sit your
ass back down we'll talk about this
later
and then she would have been very sullen
and annoyed for the rest of the night
and after the ceremony will would have
said hey let's go to the after party but
jada would have responded that she's not
in the mood to party and they need to go
home and have a long talk that's the way
it would have played out if this was a
healthy marriage or even just a real
marriage and if jayda was a decent
person and a caring wife
instead she sat there and laughed as her
husband imploded in front of the world
probably enjoyed the whole spectacle she
obviously has a thing for embarrassing
him sure he seems eager to participate
in his own self-debasement but that's no
excuse for jada smith
and so that's why she is today at the
end of the week finally canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day talk to you on monday
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavovsky our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina and hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin